investigators combing through the rubble
of Super Tuesday discover a frightening
truth tornadoes are getting more
powerful is there anything we can do to
protect ourselves
the first time wind engineer partha
Sarkar from Iowa State University
surveyed the wreckage from a tornado he
was determined to do something about it
do you may survive a tornado but your
entire life is turned upside down
because your whole house is gone whole
neighborhood is gone and that's what
bothers me if you see the cars which
have taken a hit from f5 you see it
twisted beyond recognition you know
people are no match for that kind of
wave on Super Tuesday in Tennessee alone
over 500 homes are destroyed
the cost to rebuild runs into hundreds
of millions Sarkar thinks we can prevent
the damage these new more powerful
tornadoes will bring we can do something
about it we can design these houses to
at least not get completely destroyed if
it's partially destroyed we can rebuild
it is completely destroyed and is gone
in order to figure out how to protect a
building he has to know exactly what the
winds are doing inside a powerful
tornado
to do that he has to make himself one he
contacts tornado expert bill gallus it
was probably a phone call I'll never
forget partha wanted to design the first
wind tunnel that would create a moving
tornado and wanted to discuss what ways
might we use to create a moving tornado
simulator this is the result of their
collaboration a twister in a can 18 feet
across and 11 feet high suspended over a
model target the largest and most
realistic tornado simulator ever
constructed it can recreate the same
kind of tornadoes that struck on Super
Tuesday ef-1 to the more powerful ef5
it's the only simulator that can
accurately measure how the wind loads of
a moving tornado affect different kinds
of structures once they had a large
simulator done and had to throw on the
power switch I think there are a lot of
people waiting there and scared to death
that what would happen
in the past wind tunnel research
simulated only straight line wind
this machine reveals how the circular
wind of a tornado can literally pull the
roof off a house like a cork school
new building design will now incorporate
ways to prevent this